what are you doing that okay so my dad
doesn't know which game we're gonna play
today
wait don't turn don't turn go back go
back
it's Valentine's Day we are playing
genital jousting
[Music]
oh no oh yeah is this the one that you
have done put it back
hey butt sex with a cacti what the hell
okay
oh no no don't go near me my sin don't
go near me
don't know don't go in my butt mindset
how dare you disgusting wrestling okay
cute anyway [ __ ] hey we're all on a
boat - this is surfing yeah oh my god
what is that
what shall protect you protect you oh I
wanna this is the worst game this is so
awkward oh my god okay we're gonna race
we're gonna race we're gonna race my
seat
Oh got him Oh nope yeah ooh
swimming penis Double Delight oh my god
let me get in on this no no let me get
in yeah this game is disgusting it's
foul it's another race don't go in my
butt this time please nope might say
please please finish her please
I'm meaner please nah
I don't know
damn it cop get out of here how did you
win dance okay okay okay it's Double
Delight Double Delight careful yep much
you're greedy whoever came up with this
game is too frickin genius wrestling we
go wrestle yeah don't worry about the
details always wrestling on a boat okay
this is the best party game I started to
go look at the bird penis there's a
penis may the best piece back no never
why I bid you all a very fond farewell
look I get longer oh you're still long
I am so long where it's at tell him how
long I am how are you so fast
what are you good yes pitch peanuts got
him that's a good one
how are you winning this one come for
your a s no no that's not okay all right
no stay away stay away what did I say
what an essay mites yet
stop get away from me you're disgusting
okay so fine you won this one let's
finish this off with a party mode and
whoever wins the party mode gets to
officially be called the greatest penis
okay right yeah then wrestle me huh why
don't you wrestle me show me what you
got what Double Delight okay wait I
gotta get I gotta get good points here
yeah yeah hey okay last one cactus run
okay here we go oh my god oh my
ah my said you promised you promised I
would be the best penis
stupid stupid happy Valentine's Day if
you don't have anyone to celebrate yes
you can play this game actually you need
to play with two people but I mean if
you have two controllers you can kind of
play with yourself that would be a great
I really recommend doing this but anyway
leave a like we enjoyed and as always